Good morning.
As you know, this process involves you giving a one minute presentation about yourself...
...and why you'd like this job.
We'll then have a short break before the formal interview starts.
Okay.
Please begin whenever you're ready.
Good morning.
I'd like to take this opportunity to say how delighted I am to be here.
And how glad I am to have an opportunity to tell you a little bit more about myself,...
...and why I'm the right person for you.
As you can see from my CV, I got my first degree nearly ten years ago.
And last year I completed my postgraduate degree.
I think I benefited a lot from the formal training.
In the last six years, I've worked for two companies but in similar roles.
Starting off with the South Beach Council...
...where I managed a team of ten, which was very interesting.
My most recent position was at the Technical Cove...
...where I was Chief Engineer, managing a team of twenty.
Moving on to why I want this job.
I'm an experienced engineer. I'm a good people person.
I have good communication skills.
I'm comfortable presenting to clients.
I want to work for your company for many reasons.
You are clearly a very ambitious company.
And your success over the past few years has been very impressive.
And your reputation is the envy of the industry.
If I was appointed, I would start by getting to know your team and seeing what they do.
I would then evaluate the key processes...
...and see if I had any suggestions for improvements.
Thank you.
Thank you for your presentation.
You can have a short break now before your interview begins.